este periodista ruso no habría podido
grabar Este programa en su país
las dictaduras como la rusa no saben
luchar porque nadie puede cuestionar lo
que dice el presidente
Poco después de que Rusia invadiera
Ucrania
Moscú impuso penas de prisión para
aquellos que difundan lo que denominó
información falsa para escapar a la
censura de la noche a la mañana killy
Martin off se refugió en riga la capital
de letonia
era una decisión obvia
comprendimos que en ese momento nos
enfrentábamos a un gran mal del lado del
presidente Putin Under
es el jefe de redacción de novaya gaceta
un famoso periódico independiente ruso
alrededor de 30 periodistas vinieron con
él para construir una nueva versión de
este medio de comunicación
este lugar es la redacción de un medio
de comunicación local y nosotros lo
alquilamos Esta es la nueva casa de
Nueva valla caseta
el objetivo de la redacción es mantener
informada a la sociedad rusa desde el
extranjero
un artículo como este no podría ser
publicado en un medio ruso en este
momento
no podemos llamar guerra a esta guerra
sino operación militar especial
tenemos gente en Rusia que trabaja con
nosotros por supuesto somos Muy
cuidadosos cuando hablamos con personas
que están en Rusia
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa a
Ucrania letonia ha otorgado cientos de
visas a periodistas que huyeron de Rusia
cientos de intelectuales rusos también
se han exiliado en este país
muchos viven al oeste de riga en
mala irónicamente esta ciudad costera
era popular entre la élite rusa durante
la Unión soviética
se mudó a su residencia secundaria
cuando Ucrania fue invadida la profesora
de derecho constitucional ruso estaba
conmocionada
había olvidado que Moscú existía
fue difícil darse cuenta de que tu país
que derrotó al fascismo pudiera Iniciar
una guerra tan terrible cometer
semejante crimen para poder enseñar
libremente ella y otros opositores al
régimen imparten cursos gratuitos en
línea Desde hace dos años según ella
desde febrero se han inscrito miles de
estudiantes
un soldado tiene su fusil un periodista
su bolígrafo un profesor puede enseñar
esa es nuestra arma
letonia también es el país con el mayor
número de refugiados ucranianos en
relación con su población
desde febrero más de 45.000 ucranianos
han obtenido visas Lo que equivale al
dos como a cuatro por ciento de su
población
con su familia el pasado marzo ahora
lucha por su país con una ong
locals fabricamos velas para el ejército
ucraniano hemos hecho más de 40.000
no solo velas también alimentos
medicinas y ropa abrigada la asociación
envía toneladas de paquetes humanitarios
cada semana como voluntaria tonia lucha
a su manera
Rusia y Vladimir Putin nos robaron
nuestras vidas
nuestros planes para el futuro
la asociación no tardó en apoyar a
combatientes y civiles
menos de una semana después de la
invasión a gran escala de Ucrania
encontraron este depósito
dijimos No necesitamos tanto espacio un
año después nos damos cuenta de que
necesitamos todavía más espacio creo que
para todos nuestros voluntarios esta
lucha no es solo la de los ucranianos
sino también la nuestra
este conflicto le recuerda a letonia la
ocupación soviética que se extendió
hasta 1991 desde mayo el gobierno ha
estado retirando cualquier emblema que
pueda recordar este doloroso pasado
al ejército rojo fue retirado el verano
pasado
tras estas rejas se dirigía un Coloso de
piedra de 79 metros de altura
el ataque de Rusia ha cambiado la
percepción que el público y que Europa
occidental tienen del discurso ruso
construido en torno a la historia
y a la ideología de la unión soviética
estos monumentos no son históricos son
ideológicos
cientos de monumentos han sido retirados
en todo el país solo quedan algunos
símbolos
aquí todavía hay una oz y un martillo
que pronto deberán ser retirados
esta política no fue bien recibida Por
una parte de la comunidad rusoparlante
que representa más de un tercio de la
población
algunos miembros siguen siendo afines a
Rusia
en cualquier caso esta lucha contra
Vladimir Putin le permite a letonia
voltear la página de su pasado soviético